all right so norman
yes norman it's been how many days now
oh this is day 18
18. yeah that's great this is 18 days
then uh
and you've a couple new things to report
right yeah a couple of new things to
report um
you guys would be happy to know uh
norman has a job
you got hired i got hired um
that's great it's a good company
well-known company
and uh i'm very excited about the
opportunity uh we're gonna take this a
day at a time
uh we're gonna dispel the one check
norman
you know he's dead you know so we're
going to be
um a very conducive human being a very
productive member of society
i'm really calm about it because it was
it was shocking at first
but when you really look at the totality
of everything you know god's in control
and and this is his way of saying
okay if you want me to come into your
life
then i'm going to give you some things
and i'm gonna see what you're gonna do
with them
i'm gonna love you but i'm gonna see
what you're gonna do with them so
i don't i don't look at this as being a
test um
some people might say well you're you're
not sobering
long enough well who's to say
what time god does what he does i think
there's a verse in the bible uh
ecclesiastes 3 1 there's a time a
purpose and a season for everything
so evidently it's my time it's his
purpose
and it's our season you know not too
much to shine
we have to understand to make sure that
the ego doesn't get so placated to where
i go
left right up down no we stay
god-centered
we do what we have to do do what's in
front of us don't do too much
don't do two less do what's in front of
you you know let's uh
let your god's god talent shine and this
is just a job
yeah this is not what you're used to in
your past no no it's actually
it's actually for uh an hourly wage you
know and i've
been you know a salary person but i'm
very humbled to take this
you know it's a new start it's a new
beginning you know and i think
once you grasp the newness of life you
can you can really flourish
you know you have to understand that it
is a day-by-day process whether you're
an addict or not
you know i don't think there's a normal
person on the face of this earth
some people you know say well you know
uh
you're abnormal in the rooms of the
anonymous fellowships they say
well you're an abnormal person well i
don't think there's a normal person on
the face of this damn earth
because everybody has something
i just happened to be uh formally
addicted to a substance that that
controlled me
but this addiction takes so many
different forms
yes i mean you know eating shopping
gambling yeah yeah
anything lack of courage you know a lot
of people just destructive relationships
they don't look at it as an
addiction where okay
you have drugs and alcohol on my side oh
he's an addict he's an addict
but his this person is eating every one
every hour
well no i just have a problem no it's
more than a problem it becomes an
addiction
so it can manifest itself in so many
ways you you look at
uh so many different things and how they
they play out
and um you know it's
man i'm blessed i'm blessed so many
great comments um
you guys help me so much you know i read
them every day
i start from the first video then i go
to the follow-up so i guess this is
follow-up follow-up
you know so we'll do more we're um
we're moving up you know i'm not george
i'm not wheezy but we're moving on up
and it's going to be a great
great uh great experience for me so what
do you think the
the difference is for you because i've
interviewed so many people and they're
stuck and they're they're not really
going to make progress
i can take them to rehab i can walk them
in but they'll walk out three days later
but you're doing this without rehab
you're just kind of like you turn the
corner and and you haven't looked back
and you're moving
you're making progress about getting a
job you'll be off the street soon you'll
be
you'll be well on your way to a
different life and
what is it about norman that allows you
to do that do you think everyone else
is not is lacking or just not doing it's
that word
you know what it is it's wherewithal and
but that's also has to do with
i i think it has a lot to do with loving
yourself and forgiveness
well it's the choice that i made when i
chose to to not do it anymore
and god empowered me or empowers me
excuse me every day
to not to turn away from it you know it
has to
it's an inside job i have to want to
stay sober
it's not so much that i got to stay
sober yes it's a life-threatening
disease
but i gotta want it and i think god
looked in me
no i know god looked at me and said okay
you know what
he's serious you know let me
let me empower him in ways to where he
can turn away i've had
a couple of guys walk up to me hey man
what's up norm
y'all right here come on you don't want
to take it no and they're looking at me
befuddled because you know
i'm smoking joe you know but no longer
am i smoking joe and i just made that
choice
you know and you have to have it in your
heart to do it and that's what i have
you know i just
i just don't want it anymore you know
there's so
[Music]
so many things that i can do um
and once again if i may reiterate on the
comments you know you're talking about a
springboard that that just pushes a guy
to doing the right
i don't know any of you people
yet you
you got love for me and i don't know you
and i think that i know that that's one
of those things that i've always see
i've
missed that love of my mother even
though my grandmother might have been
strict i miss that love you know that
that
that stick-to-itiveness and you guys
have those comments and i read them
every day
and it's just a springboard it's just
over and over and over again
and it pushes me into doing the right
thing
um
it's just it's just phenomenal it's like
and i told my buddy this last night he's
like where the hell did you get this
you know i said you have to embrace the
oysters of life
because contained inside the oysters of
life are pearls of wisdom
so if you grasp a hold of the oysters of
light you get a pearl of wisdom
how many oysters you get depends on you
but how many pearls you get is the one
thing that you really need to look at
because it's wisdom here wisdom there
wisdom here wisdom there
you know and you'll learn to to to to to
develop
a sense of well-being and what are
happening inside of you
is a latin word sparatas it's the
bringing out a
see what you did for me was you allowed
me to bring it out
and once i brought it out a cloak
a blanket a shield a tarp
it start falling off you know so now i
can
learn every day how to be single whole
and complete within myself
then i'll be presentable to the world to
an employer
and hopefully to some woman at all it's
got to be an amazing feeling to to share
these you know what most people would
consider very shameful
things about yourself oh yeah and then
and then just receive
all that positivity yeah i've told um
[Music]
a couple of people uh they man i've seen
your video
man i would have never told nobody that
i would have done that i said well
that's you
i said maybe you have some things inside
of you that you really really need to
get out
and you won't be stuck in the rut
anymore you'll be free
you know it's like i was in this large
hole it's almost like batman
when he stuck down in that cave you know
and um
he used the wherewithal and he had that
stick-to-itiveness and he got out
see i wanted to get out but i didn't
want to do what it takes
to get out the courage because to me
getting high was fun it was exciting
it's not funny anymore
there is no excitement i'm getting older
my kids are getting older
you know do i want to be laying in this
expensive box while they're looking at
look at my dad
he died of a cocaine overdose no
i would rather them look at me in an
expensive box and say i'm so proud of
him
because at one time in his life he was
down he got up
he did what he was supposed to do he
lived a fruitful life
and now he's going home it's gonna be a
beautiful story i think yes
the the self-love and forgiveness which
i mentioned earlier
is you know works both ways you know
you're doing it for yourself you're
forgiving yourself and loving yourself
and and other people are doing that to
you
and the more i think what people don't
understand is by being judgmental which
a lot of the commenters on youtube can
be very judgmental against certain
people i've interviewed they don't
understand what you're actually doing is
judging yourself when you're when you're
making these judgmental comments against
uh a klansman or a drug addict or a drug
dealer or a
pimp or whatever what you're actually
doing is judging yourself
and they don't see how that that and it
actually by knocking that person down
you're actually hurting yourself
somebody once told me that if
it works in the opposite way the
positivity works in the opposite
direction where it helps and
i mean you know we have so many people
with different lifestyles in this world
and
you know the acceptability that i have
is that's your life
but one a wise person told me once one
time that
if a man is just really really down
on homosexuals men
it's two things that go with that he's
either had a bad experience or he wants
to have an experience
yep there's just definitely a connection
there you know i don't know exactly what
it is but yeah i know i've seen it you
know
and you know i've uh i had gay i have
gay family members
um i know gay people and it's okay
because whatever you want to do in life
you're held accountable
for it my grandmother once told me she
said sweetheart let me tell you
something
you have a thousand dollars and you see
a 500
suit buy it but understand make sure
your bills are paid and everything else
is done and i said well why she said
because damage you only live once
and if you want that damn 500 suit buy
it
because you never know you might leave
here and say damn i never got a chance
to buy
that nice suit that i really wanted so
that's one of those things that i look
at
and there's no easy way out there's no
shortcut to that no you're going to need
courage
no oh god it takes courage
courageous is like yeah it's like the 12
steps
they have principles behind the 12 steps
it's honesty
hope faith courage integrity willingness
humility love forgiveness discipline
awareness and service
i have to put all of those in that yeah
but
i bet your courage would be the most
yeah and courage is is yes that's the
one because
i may put on this male bravado that uh
you know i'm a man but deep down inside
i'm a scared little kid
you know and and and what i'm doing now
is
is i'm leaning and asking and trusting
and relying on god to
push me into a state of mind to where i
says you know what
once i have a problem anything
i don't have to run anymore all i got to
do is open my mouth
lord i'm having a problem here could you
direct me
and i've never done that because i had a
problem with god
um we don't have a problem anymore
uh we're tight because see i seek him
every day i seek him every day and
that's what what
really catapults me into this state of
mind you know some people might
you know well you know don't let your
ego get in the way
okay that's understandable
but he's my employer even though i have
a new
job i also have a bigger
job he's my employer i'm his employee
at some point in time even through this
is there's going to come a point where
somebody's going to be put in front of
me
my job is to help them my job is not to
look down as
anybody whether they're an addict
whether they're just
have mental deterioration whatever it is
my job is not to look down
at them my job is to look at them
and extend my hand and pick them up
that's my job
that's what i have to do otherwise
i'm wasting time i'm wasting quality
smoking time as they say
so i don't want to do that hon i'm just
going to take it a day of time
so you start work uh this week yes and
uh
i'm excited about it you know i've never
i've never worked in a grocery store
but it's gonna be fun you know you know
i like to eat so
you know i'm not saying i'm gonna run
around the grocery store and eat up
everything but
it's new and and i embrace newness
today uh the fear of the unknown is
starting to dissipate because usually if
i can't touch it
taste it feel it and see it i ain't
[ __ ] with it
but god works in the unknown for me
i don't know what god does for anybody
else but he works in the unknown and he
works in the unseen
i'm beginning to know him
and for me this is just my own opinion
i see him
i see him when i look in the mirror
the path that i'm on what i'm doing
my mindset that's god not me
yes some one person wrote a comment and
said hey you know it's just not about
god it's you
well if i didn't have the fortitude the
wherewithal
and the empowerment of god [ __ ] it dude
i'm through
you know yeah you can cancel christmas
santa's not coming
it's over so
it's gonna be it's gonna be good you
know i'm enjoying it um
i haven't faced any major challenges yet
i know they're coming
life has peaks valleys rivers uh oceans
of disparity depression
i'm learning how to swim in the ocean of
life
i'm learning how to tread water in the
river of disparity
most importantly god has placed me in
his boat
of hope and that's what's propelling me
that's what's going to be good i wish
you the best of luck
doing a great job so far okay yes sir
we'll take it one day at a time
everybody out there thank you so very
much for your comments keep them coming
they drive me keep them coming all right
okay
okay
you